-Eggs, flour, water, and milk.
-That's what I used to use
for birth control.
It doesn't work.
[ Laughter ]
-Zynerma let me live again,
because I was once declared
legally dead for 15 hours.
-If your erection lasts
more than four hours,
that has nothing to do
with Zynerma...
but congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Tracy and I have
a lot of history together.
Most people think that we met
on "Saturday Night Live,"
but we go back
further than that.
Tracy and I
actually were together
at the same cooking network
back in the early '90s.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Yeah, it was called EatsTV.
-What were we doing?
-I know, man.
Between shows,
we would do these segments
where we gave the audience
cooking tips,
but to keep
our line readings fresh,
our director
wouldn't let us see the lines
until while we were shooting.
So we were reading them for the
first time right there on set.
Well, I found
some of our old footage.
-What?!
-I swear.
So, for the first time
in decades,
here is Tracy and I on EatsTV.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're watching EatsTV,
your home for recipes,
restaurants,
and really good food.
Stay tuned for tips
from the EatsTV kitchen.
♪♪
-Welcome to EatsTV.
[ Laughter ]
Coming up, I'll teach you how
to make homemade Panda Express.
Step one, break into a zoo.
Step two, steal a panda.
Step three, realize you're
in way over your head
and just order Panda Express.
Bon app--
Bon pandatite.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-I've got a great recipe
for stumpkin pie.
First, you got to find
fresh stumpkin.
But don't get one with a face.
Those stumpkins are scary.
[ Laughter ]
I hate scary stumpkins.
They's got skeleton teeth.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-My favorite foods
in this order are
cheese, chickpeas,
peas, chicks, chick cheese.
Did I say peas already?
Quiches, peaches,
cheesy Reese's,
beets, beefs --
heck, all the meats --
fries and pies,
and wings and thighs
and telling lies.
[ Laughter ]
Noodles, strudels,
Froot Loop kugels.
Yodels...
♪ Yodel-ay-hee-hoo ♪
[ Laughter ]
Oh, so hoarse.
My favorite food is horse.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-On Thanksgiving,
chew like Chewbacca.
Chewbacca used to my favorite
"Star Wars" character,
but then he got behind
on his child-support payments.
[ Laughter ]
-Tracy, here.
-Huh?
-Oh.
We really did this.
-No, here. No, here.
[ Laughter ]
Eggs -- Eggs, flour,
water, and milk.
-That's what I used to use
for birth control.
It doesn't work.
[ Laughter ]
I got eight kids off the books.
-The best cooking advice
I can give you
is to always use
fresh ingredients,
like this lemon that was just
picked this morning.
[ Laughter ]
Yummy.
I'm glad I'm doing this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I call Tony the Tiger
Anthony because of the respect
of what he does for breakfast.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-How come the cat food
is called Fancy Feast?
Do cats think
they're better than me?
Well, guess what, cat.
I can eat cat food, too.
I want chicken. I want liver.
I want to sleep in a little
basket on top of the heater
and clean myself with my tongue.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's not delivery,
and it's not DiGiorno.
It's Britney, bitch!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Don't waste your money
on expensive takeout
when you can make a delicious
meal right at home.
-I like waffles.
That's why I turned my house
into a waffle house.
I sleep on the grill.
It burns my buns.
[ Laughter ]
-Waffle House burns my buns.
-EatsTV. Who wants seconds?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh. My thanks to Tracy Morgan
right there!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, Robert and I have
a lot of history together.
Not a lot of people know this,
but back in the early '90s,
we both starred in a commercial
for an allergy medicine
called Zynerma.
-Oh, my -- That's totally right.
-Remember that?
-Yeah, that
really eccentric director.
-Oh, don't even. The director.
-He came out of French cinema,
right?
-He did. Well, he had this thing
that he wanted us
to have our line readings
be really fresh.
Right, so he didn't want us to
see our lines before the bit.
-That's right.
-So every time
we went to the commercial,
we were reading the lines
for the first time
right there on set.
Well, I found one
of our old commercials.
-No!
-Yes.
-Oh, it's about time.
-So, here for the first time
in decades is me
and Robert Downey Jr.'s ad
for Zynerma.
-Zynerma!
-If you suffer
from seasonal allergies,
then relief is finally here
with once-daily Zynerma.
Ask your doctor or pharmacist
if Zynerma is right for you.
-Before Zynerma,
my allergies would keep me
in bed all day long.
But not anymore.
Now the only thing
keeping in my bed
is my fear of tall men.
[ Laughter ]
-Side effects of Zynerma
may include thought blisters,
the mumps, hepatitis K,
gooberlycosis,
tripolar depression and slacks,
premature fatherhood,
stump lung, crispicks,
and hat failure.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Best of all, they're shaped
like Flintstone characters.
Not the pills. My nipples.
♪♪
-Zynerma shouldn't replace
your asthma inhaler,
and it can't replace...her.
Sorry, big guy,
but she's not coming back.
The sooner you accept that, the
better off we're all gonna be.
♪♪
She actually wrote you
a really long letter
explaining everything,
but I accidentally
dropped it in the toilet.
My bad.
-Alright.
Now me and you together.
-Okay.
♪♪
-Wait. Give me a second.
[ Laughter ]
Alright. Ready?
Zynerma let me live again,
because I was once declared
legally dead for 15 hours.
-If your erection lasts
more than four hours,
that has nothing to do
with Zynerma...
but congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-What the...?
There's more?
Alright.
One time, I got a Lego man
stuck in my no--
[ Laughter ]
One time, I got a Lego man
stuck in my nose.
I blew and blew and blew,
but he wouldn't come out.
He's still up there to this day.
Sometimes when I'm lying in bed
at night, I think about him --
how old he is,
if he ever got married,
if he's happy.
Then the Ambien kicks in
and I fall asleep
naked in the front yard.
♪♪
-Whoa, I just
r-realized something.
Zynerma rhymes with potato.
Wait, no. Sorry.
Tomato rhymes with "pot-ah-to."
Damn it. I just
embarrassed myself again.
I guess my dry cleaner
was right --
I'm a worthless sack of crap.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, Chad. Hey, Chad.
What are you up to, man?
-Hey, sorry, bro.
-[ Laughs ]
You know you can make --
Do you know you can make
your own homemade Tylenol?
All you need is Skittles
and vodka.
[ Laughter ]
-Ask your doctor
about Zynerma today,
then ask your doctor
for their number.
Doctors are good people to date
because they've already
seen you naked
and most of them
make a [bleep] load of money.
[ Laughter ]
-I asked my doctor if Zynerma
was right for me,
but he said, "I've never heard
of Zynerma. What is it?"
So I said,
"It's a pill, dum-dum.
Just write the prescription."
Then he said, "That's not
how prescriptions work."
So I said, "Pwease?"
And he said, "No."
So I said,
"Pwetty, pwetty pwease?"
And he said no again
and called the police.
So now I go to the veterinarian.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Here's a list of
everything I'm allergic to --
love...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-I lived in the back of
a Walgreens for three years
because my arm was stuck
in the blood-pressure machine.
-That's where I found him.
I took him home,
hosed him off in his yard,
and nursed him back to health
with Muscle Milk.
-Soon, I weighed 600 pounds.
It was a long, hard road
to lose all that weight,
and I couldn't have done it
without a good friend.
-But after his friend escaped,
I stepped in.
The rest is
rock-'n'-roll history.
-Thanks, Zynerma!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Once-daily Zynerma.
Breathe deep.
♪♪
-Had a lot of...
[ Cheers and applause ]
You got a lot of -- [ Laughs ]
-That went on a bit.
-We did a lot of commercials.
I forgot how many commercials
we ended up doing.
-Yeah. Very experimental.
-[ Laughs ]
My thanks to Robert Downey Jr.,
everybody.